[Music]
thank you everybody it is uh it's
exciting to be here mainly I'm gonna
look I'm quitting comedy soon so I don't
you guys to worry about it
I'll get out I mean I can't get out yet
cuz for one it's pretty tough to quit
something no one knows you do so there's
that hurdle there's actually no one even
acquit even if I wanted to quit no one
cares that I'm doing this like I don't
have a boss I can't just call Cosby look
I'm out alright here's why I do it my my
dad is an entertainer as well he's a
magician
still is a magician but but just in it
like he started as a clown like I don't
want to come up here and come off like I
come from some rich magic family and I'm
better than you guys alright he paid his
dues his clown dues it's weird when he
dad's a clown though it's weird every
day it made me not like clowns you know
like have you ever been yelled at by a
clown I have you're not confusing that
is to get screamed at by guys gonna
smile paint on his face
like is this good it's not good he was a
clown I was about 12 years old and from
experience I can tell you that's about
as long as you want your dad to be a
clown like when you're six and seven
there's some perks but like we need 12
and 13 kids that score likes he's still
doing that like you know what guys just
off and on all right he is almost full
time magic so let's take it easy
maybe the the fun thing though about
being comedian I like hanging out my
friends I got a buddy of mine his name's
Luis Gomez and me and Louis went to
McDonald's deke recently and we both go
we ordered our food and it would take
our food and we sit down at our table
and then Luis went to the bathroom so he
left me alone with his food so I was
like I'm gonna play a prank on him you
know so I grabbed his hamburger I
unwrapped it I took a bite out of it and
I wrapped it back up I put it back down
on his tray so that's my big prank like
when he comes back and opens his burger
I'll just like do did they eat your
burger before they gave it to you that's
crazy right is that crazy
it's a ridiculous prank it's dumb
it's harmless it should never leave the
table what should happen is Luis should
just come back he should open his burger
and his first reaction should be to look
at his best friend he's sitting with who
by the way also dabbles in comedy and
just be like hey I just wanted to run
this by you before I unexpectedly go
freak out
on this entire mcdonald's that's what i
thought would go down just too quick hey
i wanted to see if you touch my food
the only time is out of my sight before
I try to fight a group of people that
are gonna be pretty confused on why
they're fighting but instead that was
the day I learned I'm friends with a
lunatic and a guy comfortable fighting
McDonald's employees because he opened
his burger and he could not have ignored
me quicker like didn't even kind of look
like look at him so he looked like he
expected them to do it like it's
happened before and he's like again
again with this it just starts he starts
screaming at all he's like somebody my
burger how about a fight all of you till
I find out who ate my burger so he gets
up he starts walking toward them so now
I gotta jump in I can't believe it's
working like we've gotten so much
farther than I thought we could ever get
I grabbed him as a glue aside your
burger I hate it dude you got it that's
insane that you look at me that's insane
so I get him sit down it's already weird
like everybody's like looking at us it
takes like 10 minutes for people quit
filming us with their phones and that's
when it hits me I start thinking about
is like it's like you're gonna get
killed with it I think you were about to
go fight it as like let's look let's
pretend that I'm not here let's pretend
that someone did eat your burger that
worked at this McDonald's let's pretend
that really happened you were gonna go
blindly fight that guy not even trying
to like size him up like see what he
looks like
at least do you really think you could
beat up a guy that is apparently pretty
confident in himself that he's making
burgers he's then eating them
it's just sitting them out to whoever
you go then that guy's probably the
greatest fighter of all time
I honestly that you'd walk to the
McDonald's counter anybody hey who ate
my burger and all the McDonald's
employees would just part ways is they
know exactly who you're talking about
and then the very back McDonald you see
a guy standing there cracking his neck
he's got his fist in the fryer doesn't
even know it
[Music]
that's hilarious Nate bargatze
[Applause]